if myanmar's generals thought they could
silence
democracy they were wrong today
in yangon the biggest protest since
monday's coup thousands on the streets
demanding
let the military dictatorship fall they
shout
hands raised in the three-finger salute
of resistance
but the military don't want you or
myanmar's people to see this
so they shut down the internet we
managed to get these pictures out
just before
[Applause]
anger has been growing all week it
started with the tentative banging of
pots and pans
[Applause]
now it's a deafening freedom song
i feel heartbroken this man says
he's furious the military ignored the
voice of the people
but it seems myanmar's co-leaders don't
like pushback
to try to stop the demonstrations they
blocked
facebook twitter and instagram that
didn't work
and that's why the internet was next
we're very concerned about the situation
there it's it's really
um should be cause for great
international concern and i cannot
emphasize that strongly enough
this is a military with a history of
impunity and committing grave human
rights violations
we're hearing of roundups of people
there are activists journalists and
civil society members in hiding
the situation there warrants grave
concern and urgent action
with the shutters down the pitcher
inside grows even murkier
still no sign of de facto leader ang
sang tsuchi
who along with the president's due in
court next week
even their lawyer's access is limited
hello
myanmar's democratic dream is gravely
wounded
but the people have shown they will
fight to keep it alive
so far violence has been avoided but the
fear is growing
the authorities will strike brutally
when their patience
runs out siobhan robbins sky news